How long?
Three days.
I'm on earth.
And you're on earth...
hmm
I was not convinced that you would
survive the journey to Asgard.
Where's Jane?
She's resting.
She is quite exceptional.
I thought you'd been blinded by passion
but in truth you were the only one who could see
and you...
Did what needed to be done
Loki?
You did the right thing
Or like the worst mistake ever.
What?! We don't know!
Let us begin
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie!
This is going to be my new Avengers infinity Saga deleted scene with Thor becoming King Thor
This is at least the third time maybe fourth time that we've seen him been named King in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
They keep trying to name him King, but something always goes wrong. So we'll break it down
There's a completely
alternate ending that will break down
and there's a lot of this scene that I just cut down for the purposes of this video that
I think that they'll bring back around for Thor 4 love and thunder
So I'll explain the stuff that they cut out that I think that they'll bring back
We're doing the big infinity saga box set giveaway with all the blu-rays for all the movies
That's where this scene came from
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite Thor deleted scene on the video
We'll just break this down top eighth style starting with number eight
So Thor wakes up recovering from the battle at the sight of Odin watching over him
in a more dignified earthly form
Remember the other deleted scene with him in the alleyway
where he named Thor King Thor and gave him the odinforce
So in this version of the scene Odin is still wearing his armor
It's just that he Thor Loki all the Asgardians that come to Planet Earth on a regular basis late
Enchantments just basic enchantments on their armor in their weapons to disguise them
So they blend in with all the other regular people
Taika, really took that joke and ran with it during thor ragnarok
like especially thor with the version of his hammer
That was the umbrella
Like don't forget your hammer as he calls it to himself
just saying sorry as it crashes through every room in the sanctum
But he's basically sitting here telling Thor that I didn't think that you would survive the journey through the Bifrost
Because your wounds were so bad. So we just wanted you to heal for a couple days
Number Seven Odin tells Thor he'd make a very good King speaks
Very highly of Jane Foster
is basically telling him he's passing the title because the test of the early Thor movies was Thor really wanting
To be king early as thinking that he wanted to be king
and Odin thinking he wasn't ready yet
This is the point where Odin is like you're definitely ready
I'm going to retire you become king take the mantle
there was another part of this deleted scene that I cut out
where Jane Foster has a really long talk with Thor about their
relationship and about how she's afraid to go live on Asgard
and be his queen actually be queen of Asgard because as a human
She's much less advanced in the Asgardians and she doesn't want to feel useless up there
Like she's a really smart scientist on planet earth,
but all the scientists living on Asgard doing what she would be doing
Were she to move to Asgard to become queen
she'd feel completely useless among them so number six
This is some of the stuff
I think they'll bring back around and
incorporate into Thor 4 love and thunder when she becomes a version of female Thor from the comics
like the idea that she's not
completely worthless
there's a lot of questions about what's going to happen with the future of them as a couple within the MCU in the future like Thor
Seems like he's still in love with her
and the title of Thor 4 is love and thunder
so I think at least part of the movie is going to address that but there's a big question about
What's going to happen with Thor after Thor 4 love and thunder
because it doesn't sound like they're going to kill him off but Chris Hemsworth
Wants to come back and do more movies
So just open up a bookmark and Chrome for that
status pending for Thor after Thor 4 love and thunder number five
Darcy comes back during this scene telling Jane Foster that she made a big mistake to not move to Asgard with Thor like come on
We don't know what would have happened if you'd have moved up there pretty solid bet
That's another joke that they'll bring back around during Thor 4 love and thunder
I don't know if Darcy's going to be in that movie
But we do know that she's coming back during Avengers Wandavision Disney Plus episodes
They didn't say what she'd be doing during the events of that series
But because she's mostly a scientist and we know they're officially canonizing the sword
organization from the comics and clarifying that Nick Fury's space station from the spider-man far from home post-credit scene is
The SWORD space station from the comics maybe Darcy maybe Erik Selvig and Jane Foster
Tangentially are all working with sword in the events after Avengers endgame,
even though a couple of those characters like Jane Foster and Erik
Selvig we probably won't hear about till after Thor 4
like they didn't say the Erik Selvig would show up during Wandavision
number four
They also addressed this funny tongue-in-cheek moment of Loki making himself look like King doing his own fake
coronation ceremony
parody of the one that Thor got during the first Thor movie
that's actually part of a whole other deleted scene - it's basically
Loki while he's still in prison just sort of making this
Illusion for himself making it seem like he's worthy and being honoured by his people
they kind of brought that joke back around during Thor Ragnarok
at the end in the big final battle when the ship comes in and
Loki's standing on the bridge and says my people your savior is here number three
Then there's a completely different ending to Thor the dark world where Thor goes back to Asgard
before the events of Thor Ragnarok pick up
And officially takes the mantle of king of Asgard from Odin becoming King Thor
This is all happening while Odin is still alive presumably
unless you believe that this is the fake version of Odin and Loki has been masquerading as him during this entire
Deleted scene in this deleted scene ending is the complete opposite
He goes back to Asgard with Odin takes the mantle and officially becomes King Thor
It's funny how many times they've tried to turn him into King Thor in these movies
But obviously they completely changed the paradigm
because if you remember after Thor the dark world when they were heading into Avengers infinity war Avengers endgame
Chris Hemsworth's contract was going to be up after Avengers endgame.
He said he got really tired with playing the character
He didn't like this version of Thor from for the dark world
He just he just got really bored with what they were doing with the character
It wasn't until for Ragnarok came around that Taika Waititi
pitched a completely different version of Thor they completely changed the character
And Kevin Feige even said that thor ragnarok
was kind of like the beginning of a new trilogy of Thor movies
even though I don't know that they're going to do Thor 5
or anything like that
Chris Hemsworth is saying that he wants to do more Thor but I think when they say more Thor
it'll be him coming back during
future huge crossover movies future Avengers movies like Avengers 5
Number 2, there's still a lot of questions about how Taika is going to handle the story of Thor 4 love and thunder because a lot of
these characters and things will come back around like I said bringing some of the deleted scene
moments into Thor 4 love and thunder and addressing it during that movie
Thor still traveling around with the guardians of the galaxy
Asguardians of the galaxy style
Probably using Star Lords Bowflex to lose all that weight. He's still worthy of the hammer
so if they're going to do this story of female Thor
There's still the question of which hammer she uses
because hella smashed the hammer during Thor Ragnarok and Thor
technically is still worthy because we saw him weilding his hammer from Thor the dark world during avengers endgame
There's also still the question of the alternate version of Loki
who's currently running around being chased down through the multiverse by the time variance authority
and it would be weird to have a Thor movie without Loki in it
So number one early theory because you have to involve this
alternate version of Loki an easy way to include him and solve some of your
Continuity problems and plot problems with the alternate version of the hammer
You could just have him cross paths with Thor while he's trying to escape the time variance authority and through Loki's
actions an alternate version of Mjolnir comes from an alternate reality or an alternate place in the timeline
That can be the one that Jane Foster wields just because I think it'd be kind of boring to just
Reforge the old version of Mjolnir that was smashed and you have to have a version of that in order to explain
female Thor Jane Foster that doesn't really address what the main villain has to do with any of it because they'll probably
Be part of the reason for the sequence of events that leads to Jane Foster becoming worthy of the hammer
Christian Bale is rumored to be playing an intergalactic villain
everyone has a ton of theories about that but I think Marvel still trying to lock him down under contract so he hasn't officially been
Cast in Thor 4 love and thunder yet, but everyone post all your reactions and theories in the comments
Do you like this deleted scene of Thor becoming King Thor better than the original one?
And what do you think Nick Fury and sword are doing during the events of Wandavision?
Because even though Nick Fury won't be on Wandavision the sword
Organization will be part of Wandavision.
I've done videos for a bunch of other Avengers infinity saga deleted scenes
You can click here to watch all those
and you can click here for that brand new spider-man 4 special Marvel announcement video
Thank you so much for watching. Everyone Stay Awesome.
I'll see you guys tonight!